let's update the test insert read db
test to use the weather provider to get
the weather query
we'll start by changing the name to test
insert read provider
so all we need to do is take this db
query
and replace it with the equivalent
content provider one
which gets the content resolver and then
queries the content uri
now the content provider one doesn't
take a few of these parameters for
example it doesn't take table name
because that's implied by the uri nor
does it support group by
the rest of it should work pretty well
now let's run the test and verify that
it passes
and the test still passes
again it's very easy to substitute out
something that calls directly to the
database with the content provider